all right hello mama
welcome back so you were here a few
weeks ago a couple weeks ago with uh
with your pimp master jay and uh
it's nice to have you back i think this
might be an opportunity to maybe
talk more freely about your situation
are you still with him
no so you guys parted ways
and what can you tell me about that
relationship
have you have you had other pimps before
no um with
jeffrey it was it was more like
a relationship it wasn't you know
about him being a pimp or anything like
that
but like the money you would make you
would you would give to him
to handle yeah
but but as far as you guys before here's
the thing here's the thing
okay you know we would play around and
stuff like that
i would call him a 7-eleven pen
and you know i had to
i did that because
we basically met us
met as um
as being homeless and stuff like that so
when you say homeless you're actually
just living in a hotel
a hotel right right so it's not really
homeless it's just you don't have one
permanent
right which is the reason reasoning for
my prostitution
like um yeah you need to make money just
to pay the bills and keep a roof over
your head
yeah so pretty much it you know it was
about us looking out for each other what
we could do for each other
you know so i i'm glad
that's how i made him feel because you
know
come on like i mean
you know maybe before but
it's it's no no nothing like any real
pimping going on
you know
my understanding of it is it's very
hardcore
it's hard to trust
people yeah i got the impression
and maybe i'm just imagining this that
there might have been
like a little bit of like he almost felt
like a little abusive perhaps or
you know had the potential to get
physical or get to
get violent
i mean we we we just
we've been through our ups and downs um
yeah he did he
he trips um
he'll get mad and it's got it to
to the point where i may even act the
same way
with him so
i had to check my myself
and um
you know it's like we're separate you
know um
i have him here you know i don't mind
being his friend
maybe seeing him every now and then
hanging out with him
but we just can't be together
all the time or every day
you can't do it yeah
so tell me about your childhood you grew
up with uh tell me about was there any
abuse in your household
as a kid well there wasn't so much as
abuse
um i will say that you know i remember
as a small
child you know my mother and father
i i mean you know i could hear
they would throw parties you know
so what was hurtful to me
in my childhood was them splitting
up i'm you know and
i was you know
it was at a very early age for me
so i had to move around i had to live
with mom i had to live with
dad i had to live with grandmother
you know so
did you feel loved as a child you did
yeah i went through some
motions but
as as i'm going through now you know
it's like
i'm offense everything is i'm offensive
to everything
you know because i know for a fact
if i know when it comes to me
me being involved
that if i'm trying to like
if i make any suggestions it'll it'll
come out things will come out better
for whatever's going on communication
yeah you know it's like you say
you know
[Music]
you're basically doing this to help
people
well i think it just helps people
understand how these situations come to
be
and what what what's going on in certain
parts of our country just to see what
that how did this happen
how is this going on under our noses and
no one realized it was going on and
knew how it was happening now now we're
trying to learn starting to learn that
the broken families and the the amount
of abuse sexual
physical all kinds of abuse adds up to
people that are living
lives where they're just scrambling to
survive and they use things like drugs
and prostitution
sex work and all kinds of different
crime
all kinds of things just to get by and
it comes from all that well
i'm going to tell you something look
i don't i'm not in the i'm not in a
category with
everyone else this is for me to you
i don't care what's going on in this
camera right now
i'm communicating with you as
best as much as i possibly can
okay
the roles people play and and
you know things that people do
i'm not with that i i i don't do that
i'm not saying that i haven't fell into
a trance of
acting a certain way or doing certain
things
but i don't [ __ ]
i really don't have to
i really don't have to
you know so
whether it's through you
or the man upstairs
i'm pretty blessed
it's a good attitude pretty blessed i'm
like i am now because i'm i'm going i
i don't know i it it's my fa
you know i put myself in this position i
could have i should have been smarter
i should have made other decisions okay
you know but i just didn't
um but what do you wish you had done
differently
earlier i mean i just wish that i would
have
you know
not
i just went okay well it's not so much
as earlier
it's like my life now
i just wish that i wouldn't involve
myself in
to this lifestyle
so much anymore
you know i really wish i would have made
some decisions to do
other things and go elsewhere
did you finish high school
yeah you did and do you have children
yes i do how many kids do you have
three three and you raise them
um i have a 25 year old
son and i have two and one-year-old
granddaughters
so those are my three children
are you raising the young ones
hopefully hopefully
that's that's that's what that's i don't
it's like i'm i and i don't know you
know what's in me to just look past
everything else but
i really want to get to that point
i have to be santa claus
i have to be
when you say you have to be santa claus
you mean to my kids
and to yourself take care of yourself
the same way
make decisions that are good for good
for little mom
because you can you can do everything in
the world for your kids and then you
still suffer and you take the whole ship
down
well here's the thing i'm not there
now i'm too busy hanging out
i'm too busy partying um
i don't know i messed up my life
do you think maybe you're addicted to
the whole
street life fast money
all the drugs and all the the whole
lifestyle
pretty much everyone that gets into it
finds themselves
hard they find it hard to get out it
takes a very strong
mind to pull yourself out of that and
all the temptations
what would help you climb out of it what
do you think
are you using drugs currently
what do you think would help you walk
away from this life
it's just i just have to just take the
initiative to
to do it
bottom line i gotta agree not it's like
i have to have that strong moment
where i just do
what i need to do to go where i need to
go
and nothing that's going on around me or
nobody that's around me
can't make me detour from it
you need to be very determined and
focused and not let your friends and
your
all the temptations get the best of you
and you just walk away from it turn your
back on everybody and everything and
just
go your own way do what i gotta do do
what you gotta do and you're it's gonna
it's gonna be painful because you're
gonna start making a lot less money
and you're gonna start not having the
the fun and the excitement and all the
fast money and all the all the
distractions and all the things that
helped you
cope you're gonna have to just muscle it
out
and just do it on your own and no one's
going to be there to be
hold your hand while you do it it's
going to be up to you
no one no one's no one's there to like
oh yeah here's what you need to do and
here's how you do i mean there might be
some
some programs that that can help in
therapy and things like that
but it's a it's a very
very hard decision but life is full of
hard decisions
yes nice but for your kids you have a
reason to do it for yourself especially
you know i mean i'm just you know hoping
that
i'm able to do it and it goes
okay you know
yeah you know well the
the life you're living right now if you
look down 10 15 20 years down the road
it's not gonna be okay
right right you can see that right
yes so any alternative might be better
than the one you've got
going right now and
certainly the drugs and the lifestyle
and the danger of what
what you do is is going to catch up with
you at some point
life is tough life is hard
there is no easy way out not that i've
ever seen whoa
hey i'm just like whatever it ain't
nothing i haven't been through yet
yeah but i suspect that you're a strong
person and you can do whatever you need
to do you just need to put your mind to
it
and not give in to
into weakness
did you ask me something no i i all i'm
saying is you just need to
be determined to to do the right things
and not give in
you know what i don't have any
encouragement
but the determination
is there you know i mean
maybe not maybe i should maybe that came
out wrong
but it should be the opposite okay
i i can't i know that i can't keep doing
this you can't
i know that for a fact so i know if
nothing changes
i mean i don't even know if i get if i
stop and get myself together
you know or try to get myself together
i don't i don't even know um
if it's gonna stop then you know what i
mean
so i know it's not going to stop
now i can't do it
i can't do this i can't do it
it's hard yeah it's hard
all right little mama thank you so much
for coming in again
and good luck with whatever you end up
deciding to do
but it sounds like you're open to to
doing
something that might help your help you
and your kids
yes that would be great and maybe i'll
talk to you again when you do
that'd be great i'd love to have you
back okay
so cool thank you very much
thank you thanks
you